[Musique]
alors qu'il ya eu tant de pape dans
l'histoire du wetz cas se pourrait-il
qu'il y est eu une papesse
[Musique]
entre le moyen âge et de la renaissance
une légende commence à circuler un peu
partout en europe soit l'idée qu'il y
est une femme qui aurait pu mesurer le
trône pontifical elle se serait appelée
la papesse jeanne là les gens nous
racontent que cette jeune femme avait
décidé de suivre son amant déguisé
jusqu'à athènes où elle aurait eu la
chance de suivre les grands
enseignements de l'époque en théologie
en philosophie il aurait été tellement
excellente en fait dans ses
apprentissages qu'elle arrête une grande
vulgarisatrice une grande communicatrice
et beaucoup de gens se mais c'est pour
écouter ses propos elle aurait réussi à
se déplacer jusqu'à rome où les foules
se serait passé pour l'entendre
alors lorsque le pape léon 4 décède il y
aurait eu une vacance d'après la légende
de 25 mans avant le règne de benoît 3 et
donc on nous raconte que ce moment là
ces jeunes qui aurait été choisi à
l'unanimité pour devenir pape s est
qu'on lui aurait donné le nom très
commun pour les papas l'époque de jean
alors le reste mais les fonctions de
paepe plutôt de pps mais ce n'était pas
connue pendant 25 mois la supercherie a
été découverte par ce que j'aime serait
tombée enceinte et aurait accouché
littéralement dans les rues de rome
entre le colisée et le latran alors les
gens se serait rendu compte de la
supercherie
une version de la légende nous raconte
qu'elle aurait été décapitée sur place
et une autre version de la légende nous
raconte qu'elle serait décédée en poche
une pince hôtel pu en fait exercer le
pouvoir papal
au moyen âge les historiens se sont
abondamment penchés sur la question
puisque le met a été très très populaire
entre la fin du moyen âge et les années
1450 entre le règne du pape léon 4 et le
règne du pape benoît 3 il n'y a eu que
quelques semaines de vacances et non pas
25 mois aura si difficile de croire
qu'on ait pu placer un papou une papesse
intérimaire entre les deux l'autre
problème est le fait que dans certaines
versions de la légende elle meurt en
couches tant d'autres versions et les
décapiter et occasionnellement elle ne
s'appelle pas jamais albertine ou
gilberto
alors pourquoi une telle rumeur pourquoi
une telle force nouvelle eh bien il faut
dire qu'à l'époque de la renaissance
la porte était beaucoup contesté elle
qui se devait d'être chaste et
charitable ce n'était pas le cas d'une
majorité de pape
alors quoi mieux que d'utiliser les dès
qu'une femme ait pu dire plus le trompe
pontificale afin de démontrer que la
papauté n'était pas infaillible
de plus la légende a ajouté un petit
élément assez intéressant et
croustillant dans l'histoire de la
papauté soit l'idée qu'après le règne de
la papesse jeanne l'époque devait
s'asseoir sur une chaise trouvé lors de
la synchronisation a fait qu'on vérifie
leur virilité leur masculinité
or les archives du protocole de
l'intronisation des papes du vatican
sont très très très explicites et
détaillé il n'est jamais fait mention de
tel rituel
[Musique]